A duel can only take place amongst two people,
if there are three people involved it is actually
called a truel.
In 1990 a police department in Michigan staged
an entire fake weddings with undercover cops
acting as the bride and groom.
They invited numerous local drug dealers to
the wedding and busted them all at the reception.
In 2006, an Australian man tried to sell New
Zealand on eBay.
The starting price was $0.01 Australian dollars,
but it managed to reach $3,000 before eBay
closed the auction.
Three brave soviet engineers volunteered their
lives at Chernobyl to release water from the
broken reactor.
Had they not done this the nuclear fallout
would have covered most of Europe.
All three men died shortly afterwards.
The last time someone died from a spider bite
in Australia was in 1981.
Banana ketchup is popular in the Philippines.
When the Earth first formed a day lasted for
only 5.5 hours.
At 6,000 degrees celsius, the Earth's core
is just as hot as the surface of the Sun.
If you travelled at the same speed that the
Earth travels through space, you could reach
the moon in 3.5 hours.
A space suit costs $12 million.
When you eat pineapple, it is actually eating
you back.
It contains an enzyme called Bromelain that
digests proteins.
That's why your tongue tingles whilst you
eat it.
25% of Spongebob Squarepants viewers are adults
with no children.
The world's largest tyre manufacturer is LEGO.
The toy company produces 318 million LEGO
tyres per year.
A study in Sweden revealed that women with
breast implants are three times more likely
to commit suicide than the average woman.
The air quality of Mumbai is so bad that breathing
it is the equivalent of smoking two and a
half packs of cigarettes a day.
In the 16th century women often wore a black
face mask whilst outside called a visard.
It was meant to protect the woman's face from
sunburn.
The mask was held on by the a small bead inside
the mask which the woman would bite down on
to hold the mask in place.
Thus making her faceless and mute.